hello in this animated video we'll look
at reporter genes
which are genes that can report that
spatio-temporal dynamics of gene
expression
the main purpose of the reporter gene
assay is to investigate the promoter of
a gene
and whether that particular promoter is
active and how that promoter is
regulated so obviously we have a gene
promoter
and this could be a promoter of our gene
of interest let's say gene x
and in order to understand how much
transcription happens from this promoter
we need a reporter gene that would help
us to visualize
the overall
rate of transcription from this promoter
so often the reporter gene is a gfp
which is easy to visualize but now let
me tell you that there could be
different modes by which we can
visualize our reporter gene the most
common one is gfp where this gfp gene
sequence give rise to gfp protein and it
fluoresces which can be detected so
overall it's a fluorescence based
detection
it's very popular these days
there could be also enzymatic detection
where under the promoter we have the lag
z gene which codes for beta
galactosidase now if we give
substrate it might lead to production of
colored products and that's an enzyme
based colorimetric reporter
there could be also luciferase based
reporter which is a
bioluminescence-based reporter it
encodes for a luciferase enzyme
which can ultimately give rise to
bioluminescence and that can be detected
so there are different strategies by
which we can visualize the promoter
output
so for simplicity let's talk about the
gfp based reporters for a moment and try
to understand whether we can use it for
biomedical research and how we can use
it for biomedical research
now initial days
the lag z reporter was very popular
it provides the information about tissue
level expression for example here you
can see in a fly embryo this particular
gene is expressed in a
patterned fashion
but it doesn't have a really great
resolution
we don't have a cellular level
resolution at this point
and that is why fluorescence reporters
are really
interesting because they not only
provide
cellular and molecular level
resolution but also they can be
done on let's say live specimen so you
can track these gene expression dynamics
over a long time that's a big advantage
now let's talk about what questions can
be answered using reporter gene
assets you can ask that is my gene of
interest is expressed in a particular
tissue or a cell type you can also ask
that if my gene of interest is expressed
more or less upon a drug treatment or
let's say a pathological situation
one can ask that if the particular
promoter is a strong promoter or a weak
promoter
all these questions can be answered
using reporter assay let's try to
understand how
so let's talk about
whether
our particular promoter is tissue
specific or a cell type specific
so in this case
we clone our
reporter gene underneath the promoter in
expression vector
and then transfect that into different
cell types in this case we have taken a
epithelial cell neuronal cell and let's
say a fibroblast
and our goal is to monitor the tfp
fluorescence because the gfp
fluorescence would tell us about the
presence of
or the expression of these gene
we noticed in this hypothetical
experiment that the gfp fluorescent is
visualized in epithelial and fibroblast
cell but not the neuron that means our
gene of interest is selectively
expressed in epithelial and fibroblast
cells and it's not expressed in neuronal
cell types
next we can also ask whether my gene of
interest is expressed more or less upon
a pathological condition
so in this case
we
transfect our cell line
with our reporter construct just to
visualize the transcription of
gene x
and try to understand how promoter of
genex is activated then we subdivide
these cell cultures into two groups
one group is treated with a vehicle and
another group is treated with a vehicle
plus the drug
now then we can analyze the fluorescence
and plot their intensity
now if there is more fluorescence
intensity that would mean the
transcription is more in this case in
this hypothetical situation we can see
drug x lead to increase in the
transcription of the gene x because the
fluorescence intensity is more than the
vehicle treated condition
so it gives us an instant idea about
the gene expression under a particular
physiological or pharmacological
situation
lastly we can ask
is the particular promoter a strong
promoter or a weak promoter
and that can be done
by these reporter acids so generally
this is a promoter region for our gene
and this is the gene body
now the rna polymerase and the overall
initiation complex would bind to the
promoter and it would lead to the
transcription
in this case we are going to take the
promoter and instead of putting the gene
body sequence we are going to put the
gfp sequence underneath
obviously this jfp sequence would give
rise to gfp protein
now let's say in case of promoter a we
have
this many transcripts but in case of
promoter b
we have
less transcripts so less gfp would be
produced and if we quantify the
fluorescence with the fluorescence
microscope we can overall understand
how much or how less
the expression is and ultimately we can
plot graphs for promoter a and promoter
b to understand
whether it is a weak or a strong
promoter obviously a strong promoter
would lead to more transcription right
so promoter a in this particular example
is stronger than promoter b
so now we understand how we can use
reporters to answer various scientific
questions
now
let me tell you that in these days we
can use gfp based fluorescence reporters
to understand cell signaling activity
let's say this is a cell
and here we have a promoter for a target
gene of a signaling pathway
now underneath that promoter we can put
the reporter gene
and this is a signaling reporter right
now so whenever the particular pathway
is active we should see the gfp
fluorescence
so when we see gfp fluorescent it would
tell us that the pathway is on and when
we don't see gfp fluorescence or low gfp
fluorescence that would tell us the
pathway is off
so ultimately the gfp becomes a readout
of the on or off status of a signaling
pathway and this is how we can track the
dynamics of cell signaling pathway in
real time
other than that there are also
activity-based reporters so let's say
when a neuron is active and it's firing
there are certain gfp based reporters or
certain receptor
certain kind of reporters which can
report us about the calcium levels in
the neuron or let's say a voltage change
inside the neuron if you want to learn
more about these neuronal activity
reporters you can click on the i button
to know more
anyway you can get notes for these
particular topic in my facebook chat
facebook
page the link is provided in the
description
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe to let me know in the comment
whether it's useful you can support my
channel in patreon if you're an indian
user you can use bim upi to support my
channel my courses are present in an
academy you can use my code ap10 to get
a 10 percent discount if you wish to
connect with me via social media this is
my social media handle and all the links
are provided in the description
thank you see you in next time